salut à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition d'en quête d'europe
dans cette émission je vous emmène en
sicile là bas comme partout en italie on
cherche à renflouer les caisses en
vendant le patrimoine de l'état
ensuite direction la grèce depuis
l'embargo mise en place par la russie
après la guerre en ukraine les
agriculteurs grecs souffrent
particulièrement
enfin terminus en espagne depuis
quelques années le business de la
procréation médicalement assistée
explose mais d'abord on part en italie à
naples plus exactement il y a quelques
années a éclaté le scandale de la têt la
des fio qui la terre de feu c'est louis
sybille qui nous en parle
oui quelle est cette histoire de la
terre de feu
ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est
qu'il ya 30 ans l'état oblige les
entreprises à devoir traiter leurs
déchets du coup un marché s'ouvre hélas
la mafia s'engouffre dedans en proposant
des tarifs imbattables
ce n'est pas un marché public c'est un
marché entre entreprises en l'espace de
20 ans quatre cent mille camions vont
déverser 10 millions de tonnes de
déchets dans la région de campanie dans
la région napolitaine et donc il va
forcément y avoir un impact sanitaire
énorme à cause de la pollution comme on
va découvrir dans leur montage
l'arrière-pays de naples la campagne
felix la campanie bienheureuse
depuis quelques années ces terres
fertiles porte un nouveau nom la terre
de feu et pour cause des montagnes de
déchets brûle jour et nuit au milieu des
champs et des vergers l'internet faut
que c'est ça la terre de feu et déchets
donner aux flammes
ce brasier date de cette nuit comme vous
pouvez le voir il ya de tout une
bouteille de solvant de vernis des
déchets jardinage découdront nicher il
ya vraiment l'impossible ici
si à oman il ya vraiment une mauvaise
surveillance du territoire ceux qui font
ça le font tranquillement en toute
impunité
pour eux il n'y a aucun risque d'être
arrêté ou pris en flag angelo fair use
ne les nomme pas directement mais les
responsables sont connus ils ont même un
nom la camorra la mafia locale
en 20 ans à la russie a trusté le marché
du traitement des déchets appels
d'offres truqués administrateurs
corrompu et surtout tarifs imbattables
jusqu'à dix fois moins cher car la mafia
ne traite pas les déchets elle et
brûlent ou les enfouit de quoi gagner un
très gros pactole près de 30 milliards
d'euros
conséquence de ces décharges illégales
un impact sanitaire désastreux bawara
messina est une rescapée
cette jeune italienne a été atteinte
d'une tumeur du sang très rares les
nappes phréatiques sont pollués elle
fait donc attention à tout ce qu'elle
boit on n'utilise que cette eau qui est
filtrée par une banque de l'eau
communale
donc nous on y va on emporte les
bouteilles en plastique et un échange
ils nous donnent des bouteilles d'eau
filtrée maintenant guéries elle a écrit
un livre pour témoigner je savais que
sur notre territoire
il y avait des décharges illégales et je
savais qu'il y avait des brasiers
on en avait entendu parler
et on l'avait senti mêmes vues à partir
du moment où j'ai commencé la
chimiothérapie à la clinique polyvalente
j'ai rencontré énormément de personnes
qui habitaient ici même dans ma rue
comme moi et avait la même
pathologiquement j'ai donc compris qu'il
y avait une forte corrélation une
corrélation que ne fait pas l'état
italien
une étude épidémiologique a pourtant été
menés il y aurait dans la région un taux
de mortalité de 10 % supérieur à la
moyenne nationale
ce docteur a remis plusieurs expertises
sur les déchets aux autorités
judiciaires de nappes
selon lui ce qui est avant tout
révélateur c'est l'âge des patients des
études ont démontré une augmentation des
tumeurs cérébrales chez les mets bags
l'enfant mais pas un sujet qui suivit
les influences environnementales
on a fait il ya dix ans flow siècle ce
qui est important c'est qu'on constate
une augmentation significative non
seulement des tumeurs cérébrales mais
aussi une augmentation des malformations
km au significative d'éléments formative
l'italie est gagné par la psychose
les marques barilla ou encore fin du ce
n'achète plus de produits de la terre de
feu
conséquence certains agriculteurs
n'arrivent plus à joindre les deux bouts
d'autres font du bio c'est le cas de
nicolas cecere il posait de 300
bufflonne par chance son terrain n'a pas
été empoisonné
ici tous les agriculteurs ont vu la
camorra pourrir leur sol certains ont
même dû céder dé terrain
beaucoup se sont tus de peur des
représailles à la fois complice est
victime on sent pas le temps passer nous
avons beaucoup souffert de cette
situation dans la terre de feu il ya eu
une baisse de la demande de mozzarella
et donc une répercussion directe sur le
prix du lait la révélation de cette
catastrophe écologique et sanitaire a
fait réagir les gouvernements italiens
certains champs été mis sous séquestre
des outils techniques et juridiques se
sont étoffés mais c'est encore
insuffisant pour la procureure de la
région qui se confronte à la mafia tous
les jours nous avons un problème en
italie
c'est que les délits sur l'environnement
sont punis par de simples contraventions
encore aujourd'hui et de ce fait il ya
prescription très rapidement aulas le
travail ne peuvent pas balade on allait
mais en ce moment le parlement est en
train de valider une loi très
importantes qui arrivent enfin équipe
unie avec des peines beaucoup plus
lourde ce type de crime
accompagner les vapes ici mais oui toi
t'es pas d'idées en juin dernier la
ministre de la santé a promis 25
millions d'euros pour permettre à la
population de faire des dépistages
mais l'argent n'est toujours pas arrivé
600 millions d'euros ont été débloqués
fin 2013 pour assainir plusieurs sites à
ce jour un seul et dépollués ironie du
sort la dépollution devient peu à peu un
nouveau marché et la mafia pourrait bien
profiter de cette nouvelle manne
l'assainissement de sa propre solution
oui on découvre l'ampleur de la
pollution dans votre reportage est ce
qu'il ya des actions en justice qui ont
été menées il ya notamment une action en
justice qui a été menée et qui a réussi
c'est en 2013 la cour européenne de
justice a contraint la raison compagnies
à payer 25 millions d'euros au motif de
pollution de la région après il faut
bien comprendre que en italie l'appareil
judiciaire se met tout doucement en
place
pour l'instant ce sont surtout des
amendes mais un décret a été publié en
2013 ou le délit de combustion des
déchets a été créé et qui est puni de 3
ans à 5 ans de prison
mais pour l'instant personne n'a été
emprisonné et qu'en est il justement de
cette dépollution - est-ce qu des
actions ont été mises en l'air alors si
son millions d'euros ont été débloqués
pour dépolluer simplement ça met
beaucoup de temps parce qu'il faut
repérer les endroits qui sont polluées
c'est souvent anarchique alors il ya
quelques endroits maintenant bien connue
mais il faut quand même les retrouver
alors pour les retrouver il faut
questionner souvent les villageois les
agriculteurs qui n'osent pas trop dire
qu'ils ont enfoui dans leurs propres
champs ces déchets la moyenne en
moyennant rétribution de la mafia ou
alors engager des personnes qui puissent
repérer avec des appareils
mais tout cela en fait prend du temps et
donc pour l'instant un seul site a été
dépollué et louis j'imagine que tout
ceci a une incidence sur l'économie de
la région
bien sûr la compagnie c'est un peu le
grenier de l'italie l'agroalimentaire
représentent 5 milliards d'euros de
revenus chaque année ses 65 mille
salariés
alors forcément eu un impact économique
très important avec l'annoncé de la
pollution de l'air et de l'eau par
exemple les éleveurs de bufflonne qui
produisent la mozzarella qui produisent
75 % de la mozzarella sur le territoire
national et bien leurs revenus ont chuté
de 40 % en l'espace de quelques années
un désastre donc merci louis en italie
pour aller chercher de l'argent on est
toujours plein d'idées un village de
sicile voyant sa population quitter les
lieux a décidé de vendre des maisons à 1
euro c'est faustine s'ingénia ce qui
nous en parle
faustine pour vous italie vend ses
bijoux de famille est ce que c'est vrai
oui et non oui parce que de très
nombreuses communes rurales en italie
sont complètement exemple et comme
beaucoup de collectivités européennes et
elles sont obligées de faire appel au
privé pour restaurer leur patrimoine
que ce soient des particuliers ou des
entreprises alors nous on a pris
l'exemple de ce petit village en sicile
gandji qui vend ces maisons pour un euro
symbolique mais des exemples comme celui
là il en existe des dizaines rien qu'on
l'italie après dire que les talibans ses
bijoux de famille c'est un peu un
raccourci parce qu'il existe de nombreux
garant dans la loi italienne pour éviter
que l'on vende le colisée où la fontaine
de trevi et puis quand on connaît la
complexité des procédures italienne là
aussi on a un vrai rempart contre ce
genre de dérives
donc on vous suit à gandhi voici gandji
un village de montagne au coeur de la
sicile avec ses églises ses ruelles
tortueuses ses papilles qui chante et
ses maisons à 1 euro
des maisons typiques des années 20
laissé à l'abandon en plein centre ville
ces touristes singapouriens sont venus
spécialement pour en visiter avec un
agent immobilier
mais ça c'est quoi ça c'est l'ancêtre du
réfrigérateur
c'est naturellement fois les visiteurs
sont très intéressés malgré le coût de
la rénovation au moins soixante mille
euros donnés ces maisons pour un euro
symbolique
c'est l'idée de giuseppe fait rare et
l'eau le maire de ce village de 7000
âmes depuis les années 20 les conditions
de vie et le manque de travail on peut
un peu vite et gandji de ses habitants
alors il ya cinq ans le maire a lancé
cette opération très bien mais la
première année on en a vendu aucune
ensuite en 2010 on a fait les premières
ventes et de là il ya eu un véritable
boom au niveau international les tests
année ap oui désormais nous avons plus
de 1000 demandes pour acheter des
maisons à un euro des demandes de france
du brésil d'inde du japon
plus de 80 maisons à 1 euro ont déjà été
vendus et en échange les acheteurs
s'engagent à les restaurer dans les
trois ans avec des artisans locaux
un moyen de doper l'économie du village
sans aucun investissement public
mais outre le prix ce qui séduit les
acheteurs c'est la sécurité de leurs
investissements qu'angie est souvent
citée comme une ville bien gérée
de quoi éviter toute infiltration
mafieuse la setil heureusement la sicile
est connu à l'étranger à cause bien sûr
de la mafia mais vous savez le fait que
nous soyons dans les terres loin des
grandes voies de communication
nous allons sans doute préservé
qu'angie est loin d'être un cas isolé
des biens publics est inoccupée l'italie
n'en manque pas et pas seulement en
sicile nous voici maintenant à rome cet
hôpital pourtant situé dans l'une des
rues les plus commerçantes de la
capitale est à l'abandon avec environ 46
mille terrains et bâtiments comme celui
ci l'état est à la tête d'un patrimoine
c'est cible estimée à près de 60
milliards d'euros et celle qui
centralise tout celle agency adèle des
manioc qui dépend directement du
ministère de l'économie et des finances
sa mission gérer touché patrimoine et le
vendre si nécessaire on a des villas des
châteaux des phares des villages des
couvents on a le phare de bruz coolio a
langouste à est une des plus belles
pièces notre catalogue
ah le voilà c'est celle ci le superbe
hôtel de termes de san pellegrino rien
l'objectif principal dans la
valorisation de ses biens ce n'est
absolument pas de remplir les caisses à
tout prix mais de réduire les coûts car
pour la collectivité
tous ces biens inoccupés coûte très cher
alors bientôt un colisée où implanter au
privatiser impossible le ministère des
biens culturels veille au grain grâce à
un solide arsenal législatif le scénario
paraît bien rodé pourtant parmi les
biens d'exception sur le marché certains
ne trouvent pas preneur dans l'un des
quartiers les plus chics de rome
cet ancien hôtel des monnaies est
inoccupé depuis une dizaine d'années
tomasso dit à nos économistes
spécialistes du patrimoine public a son
explication le privé ne peut pas tout
l'état doit aussi mettre la main à la
poche pour certaines infrastructures par
exemple cet immeuble pourrait devenir un
hôtel de luxe un centre de conférences
ou encore un centre commercial
il faudrait alors un système de parking
pour que les voitures puissent se garer
sous la valoriser son patrimoine
culturel quitte à le vendre pour
développer un tourisme de luxe
voilà le pari de l'italie une manière de
remplir les caisses de l'état parfois
taxé de grande braderie par ses
détracteurs
fostino emmener au bout de cette
opération est ce que ça a été un succès
oui ça a été un succès il ya une
centaine de maisons qui ont été vendus
mais siguret vous n'aura qu'il en reste
à peu près autant qu'ils n'ont pas
trouvé preneur il faut dire que comme on
le voit dans le sujet elles sont assez
délabré il faut les restaurer dans les
trois ans et puis certains acquéreurs
potentiels ont été nettement refroidi
par la complexité de l'administration
italienne
la commune de grandes j ai donc passer à
la vitesse supérieure maintenant elle
donne purement et simplement ces maisons
et elle s'occupe d'une grande partie de
l'aspect bureaucratique donc tout est
beaucoup plus simple la nouvelle a fait
le tour du monde s'était même dans le
new york times en juin vernet alors si
vous voulez acheter une maison à gandhi
et il est encore temps en revanche pour
éviter toute déconvenue faites vous
quand même conseillé par un bon notaire
ou un bon avocat qui connaissent bien la
législation en sicile bombe à écouter le
message est passé
mais est ce que ce type d'initiative ne
suscite pas la polémique
si bien sûr beaucoup de voix s'élèvent
pour rendre certains de ses biens
incessibles c'est même le cas de
plusieurs députés européens qui parle
d'évasion patrimoniale une évasion du
patrimoine historique et culturel de
l'europe qui est vendu à des étrangers
il souhaiterait qu'on mette en place une
politique culturelle à l'échelle
européenne qui soit presque
protectionnistes et puis qu'on développe
aussi l'alternative que représente le
mécénat mais là on est un peu dans une
impasse
l'union européenne et ses états membres
ont ils vraiment les moyens d'une
politique culturelle digne de ce nom
dans le contexte actuel ce n'est pas
vraiment la priorité merci faustine
merci n'aura exergue économiquement la
grèce est particulièrement touchée par
l'embargo russe mis en place après le
conflit en l'ukraine
en première ligne les agriculteurs samia
de chira étaient à leur rang
samia vous êtes vous intéressé à
l'embargo russe en grèce alors qu'il est
effective dans toute l'europe
c'est tout simplement parce que quand on
parle de tension entre la grèce et
l'union européenne c'est quasiment
toujours pour parler de la réduction de
la dette
et tout ça ça a éclipsé un autre point
de discorde qui est très fort entre
athènes et bruxelles c'est les sanctions
que l'union européenne a prises contre
la russie alors pour rappel c'est des
sanctions qui ont été prises suite aux
conflits ukrainien et en représailles
moscou a décrété un embargo alimentaire
sur tous les produits occidentaux donc
européen et ça pour les producteurs y ça
a été une véritable catastrophe
au pied du mont vernon où s'étendent les
vergers du nord de la grèce dans la
région devait rien la culture de la
pêche fait vivre plus de vingt mille
personnes
un commerce essentiellement tournée vers
la russie
mais depuis août dernier moscou interdit
l'importation de produits
agroalimentaires européens un embargo
qui risque de mettre l'économie locale à
genoux bonjour des rimes jour causé des
dommages
konstantinos tourne pas guéri ce travail
dans les vergers depuis l'âge de 10 ans
il cultive exclusivement dépêche
en ce qui me concerne j'ai subi de
lourdes pertes avec cette histoire j'ai
dû sacrifier 50 % de ma production pour
en faire du jus j'en ai aussi envoyé une
partie aux associations caritatives
des distributions gratuites
subventionnés par l'union européenne
mais pas de quoi couvrir un coût de
production à 30 centimes le kilo c'est
intenable pour un producteur ni aucun
intérêt à cultiver jamais seul à la
barre konstantinos nous emmène à la
coopérative agricole de nagusa qu'il
préside ce mois-ci c'est la saison des
pommes
hommes qui étaient normalement destinés
au marché russe avec la fermeture de ce
marché on a un problème de distribution
on ne sait pas où les vendre à travers
les producteurs c'est toute l'économie
locale que déstabilise l'embargo les
saisonniers les usines d'emballage et
bien sûr les transporteurs fassent part
certainement le mien je vais vous
emmener à cannes devéria en août dernier
plus de 3000 camions se sont retrouvés
bloqués à la frontière et ont dû revenir
avec leur cargaison
on s'attendait à ce que les russes nous
fascine travers l'espace et ceux qui
étaient bloqués mais ça ne s'est pas
fait après talion dû revenir à ma perdu
beaucoup d'argent dans la région
l'embargo amis serait de 300 chauffeurs
au chômage partiel
sincèrement pour ne rien vous cacher je
commence à apprendre une nouvelle langue
étrangère si jamais j'ai besoin de
partir d'ici pour trouver règle aussi
précis
bataille aujourd'hui oui je suis venu
pour tailler mais il fait froid ce matin
yanis petit producteur de pommes reçoit
la visite d'un représentant de syriza
très vite la discussion s'oriente sur
l'embargo
je suis en colère contre l'union
européenne parce que dans l'intérêt de
certains pays
ils nous ont mis dans une situation sans
rien nous demander un discours repris
par series 1 qui accuse l'europe d'avoir
sacrifié les pays du sud
le parti promet de tout faire pour lever
l'embargo russe
nous avons promis de quitter le régime
de sanctions l'été dernier quand le
camarade type race est venue dans la
région
mais cette position est beaucoup d'échos
au sein de la population locale c'est
explique la vague de soutien des
agriculteurs pour syriza parce que je
vois ce parti comme finalement le seul
espoir pour régler leurs problèmes
mais pour l'instant embargo reste en
vigueur et il promet de faire encore
beaucoup de dégâts en grèce amano lada
les serres s'étendant à perte de vue
on y cultive des fraises exporté à 80%
en russie un marché vite récupéré par
les producteurs des pays voisins la
turquie a commencé à gagner des parts de
marché a d'ailleurs est la burla
produits qu'elle peut exporter pape et
la plupart de ses produits et les
exporte en russie donc il en profite
pour les fraises et pour tous les autres
de ressentiment pour autant vers la
turquie
c'est bien à l'union européenne quand
volent les producteurs grec dans un pays
déjà très remonté contre les cure
d'austérité imposée par la troïka
samia comment vont-ils ses producteurs
depuis votre reportage à la situation
reste assez difficile pour ceux qu'on a
rencontrée dans le nord en tout cas il
ya eu des conditions climatiques qui
sont venues se rajouter à ce problème
d'embargo et qui leur ont fait perdre 50
% de leur production quand même la bonne
nouvelle c'est que les aides européennes
depuis qu'on a tourné ce reportage ont
enfin été versés aux producteurs
et puis eux de leur côté il essaye quand
même de s'adapter il réoriente en fait
leurs exportations vers des nouveaux
marchés l'europe de loi s'il n'arrive
pas encore à pénétrer ces marchés là par
contre c'est au proche-orient et en
egypte qu'ils arrivent de nouveau à
vendre leurs produits même si c'est pas
autant que ce qu'ils arrivaient à vendre
en russie est ce qu'il ya eu des
changements sur le plan diplomatique
alors les choses restent encore très
compliqué entre l'union européenne et la
russie c'est loin de se débloquer ce que
l'union européenne en fait vient de
prolonger les sanctions pour six mois
contre la russie donc ça va courir
jusque fin janvier 2016 et le même
schéma se répète encore puisque du coup
un représailles la russie elle-même a
prolongé d'un an son embargo sur les
produits alimentaires européens donc a
priori sur le plan diplomatique c'est
mal parti
sauf que ça se débloque d'une autre
manière en fait c'est un rapprochement
entre la grèce et la russie sur le plan
politique les plusieurs visites du
premier ministre grec alexis tsipras ce
en russie il a été reçu par vladimir
poutine et vladimir poutine a annoncé
qu'il allait contourner en quelque sorte
alléger l'embargo pour la grèce alors
comment il va faire en fait ils vont
créer des sociétés mixtes nous
probablement des sociétés grecques aux
russes ce qui fait que les grecs
pourront exporter leurs produits sans
que ce soit considéré comme des
exportations merci samia merci après la
belgique et les pays-bas l'espagne fait
figure d'eldorado pour les couples en
mal d'enfant et la procréation
médicalement assistée
là bas c'est un véritable business et
c'est cécile 6e qui nous en parle cécile
pourquoi tant de couples français se
rendent dans l'espagne gagnera tout
simplement parce qu'en france il ya une
crise du don d'ovocytes en 2012
il n'y a que 4 122 femmes qui ont donné
leurs ovules alors que cinq fois plus de
couples étaient en attente
il ya donc une vraie pénurie et les
ovocytes reviennent en priorité aux
femmes qui ont eu des soucis de santé
les autres doivent attendre c'est le cas
de juliette que nous on a suivi en
espagne donc dans une de ces cliniques
spécialisées à valence
si miraculé il y a deux ans c'est ici
dans cette clinique de valence que le
miracle s'est produit
juliette a reçu un nouveau site féconder
avec le sperme de son mari
neuf mois plus tard elle était enfin
maman d'une petite fille enfin car
juliette n'y croyait plus femme active
elle s'est décidée tard a fondé sa
famille compte cinq ans voilà on attaque
voilà je vais y arriver facile et puis
bah elle non ça fonctionne pas donc on
commence à se rapprocher du corps
médical et puis là on commence à vous
faire comprendre 35 ans c'est un âge
quand même assez tardif pour avoir des
enfants
je leur ai mieux fallu faire c'est entre
25 et 30 ans donc voilà ça devient
compliqué compliqué le couple s'engage
alors dans un véritable parcours du
combattant
on commence par des petites stimulation
hormonale avec des petits les petits
comprimés bon ça fonctionne pas on passe
à des inséminations artificielles à la
phase suivante
et puis ensuite on arrive aux pma j'en
ai fait huit au total
donc au bout de lui fit voilà j'ai
décidé d'arrêter parce que j'en pouvais
plus psychologiquement je n'en pouvais
plus est ces combats me fatiguer j'en
voyais pas de tissu positives 6 ans
d'acharnement et pas de résultats son
mari ne veut pas entendre parler
d'adoption
après un an et demi de réflexion
juliette se résigne au don d'ovocytes
ç'a fonctionné du premier coup c'est pas
le profil que j'espérais c'est pas comme
ça que j'espère avoir un enfant
maintenant que ça fonctionne évidemment
je suis quand même contente de mon
parcours et maintenant je reviens une
deuxième fois pour avoir une famille
peut-être à 43 ans la française revient
sur ses pas elle veut agrandir la
famille et tente sa chance avec les
ovules conservé par la clinique les
franchement
le mieux mettre aussi des couples comme
celui de juliette le docteur galop en
voit défiler près de 400 chaque année
l'espagne est devenu un eldorado pour
les femmes infertiles entre 80 et 90%
des coupes que je reçois sont des coupes
qui devrait bénéficier d'un traitement
français pas des couples qui sont hors
la loi c'est à dire c'est des couples
hétérosexuels dont la femme à moins de
43 ans qui peuvent attestent qu'ils sont
mariés ou qui peuvent attester d'une vie
commune d'au moins deux enfants sont pas
des femmes seules ou des femmes
homosexuelles ou des femmes qui ont plus
de quarante trois ans pour la grande
majorité donc c'était vraiment des
couples qui devrait bénéficier d'un
traitement en france et qui peuvent pas
parce que il ya un problème d'accès il
ya très peu de donneuses et donc les
listes d'attentes sont très longues
en france le don est gratuit et anonyme
et les donneuses doivent déjà être maman
pour le fondateur des cliniques heavy
josé rémory ce système est archaïque et
modèles offrent un tel nof le modèle
français ne fonctionne pas en espagne
c'est la règle de la compensation
économique la régulation des doigts être
décidées par l'état des formes de telle
sorte qu'elles tonneaux le monde que
tout le monde et qu'elles reçoivent une
compensation à la hauteur au fipa
désagréments support des collèges
comment ça va ça va merci oui marta est
étudiante en médecine à 26 ans elle a
déjà donné ses ovules à quatre reprises
sa motivation aider des couples
infertiles
mais pas seulement elle reçoit à chaque
fois 900 euros pour moi c'est bien parce
que pendant mes études je n'ai pas
beaucoup de temps pour travailler et
étudier en même temps donc c'est une
manière rapide de toucher de l'argent ça
me permet d'être indépendante
je pense que c'est un bon complément
financier consultation visite
gynécologique neuf jours de traitement
par piqûre et ponction sous anesthésie
générale
la rémunération bien surtout compenser
la lourdeur de l'acte médical
un bond qui est si simple si pas comme
donner son sang ou par non
spermatozoïdes parce que le nom de vos
sites c'est comme si on soumettait un
cycle de fécondation in vitro n'est
toujours des risques d'infection
d'hémorragie et puis à les récits sont
liés à l'anesthésié donc ce panneau dans
une compensation financée par les
couples infertiles qui doivent aussi
payer les différents examens les
médicaments les six jours à la clinique
et le voyage au total l'escapade
méditerranéenne leur coûte près de 7000
euros le prix d'une famille
un luxe réservé aux personnes aisées
cécile c'est clairement un business oui
il ya plus d'une centaine de cliniques
sur le territoire espagnol de ce type là
des cliniques qui attire 10 % de
français qui génère un chiffre
d'affaires de 350 millions d'euros
ils ont des techniques en fait très
rôdée pour attirer les clients français
comme on le voit dans le reportage et
des médecins de nationalité française
qui travaillent là-bas pour mettre en
confiance les patients et d'autres
techniques c'est la simplicité des
démarches moyennant forcément des tarifs
élevés 7 à 8000 euros pour un enfant et
cécile depuis quelques années il ya
aussi un nouveau marché celui de la
congélation d'ovocytes où il n'aura vous
savez que les chances d'avoir des
enfants avec l'âge diminue par exemple à
30 ans une femme à 75% de chances
d'avoir un enfant
à 35 ans ce taux il passe à 66 % et à 40
ans et 44 % de chances d'avoir un enfant
bref de plus en plus de femmes s'y
mettent tard parce qu'elle mène une
carrière
du coup pour mettre toutes leurs chances
de leur côté elles vont en espagne pour
faire congeler leurs ovocytes la
pratique n'étant pas autorisée en france
l'idée c'est de les congeler et de faire
une fécondation in vitro une fois que l
on trouvait peut-être l'homme idéal
là aussi c'est une opération qui coûte
cher un peu plus de 2500 euros la
ponction d'ovocytes
souvent il n'y en a pas qu'une en plus
il faut compter aussi les voyages les
allers-retours en espagne au total ça
peut coûter jusqu'à 10000 euros
et souvenez-vous d'ailleurs il ya des
entreprises qui ont incité leurs
employés à les congeler leurs ovocytes
on pense à google apple ou facebook oui
et d'ailleurs à l'époque ça avait
provoqué un tollé monstre merci cécile
merci non un voile a fait la fin de
cette émission merci à l'auberge de
jeunesse yves robert et à la fédération
des auberges de jeunesse de nous avoir
accueillis pour cette émission nous on
se retrouve très vite sur public sénat
et tous les jours sur publicsenat.fr
ciao
ce soir